I woke up this morning knowing I would
have to go to the Fifty Shades screening
however I got the good news that there
is a Deadpool 2 trailer out there so
it's time for me to do a trailer talky
thing me talking about the trailer in a
video that I'm gonna call review in the
title it's not really a review whatever
I do need a haircut though when we meet
cable we see what we would expect with
cable and he is the man with a dream in
a teddy bear
I really don't still have my teddy bear
from childhood it's at my mom's house so
we see a cybernetic eye whose arm which
then is a green screen sleeve and
Deadpool starts bitching about it like
why don't this by gel effects them it's
not like we're CG eyeing a mustache out
or anything guys reverence which if I'm
being nitpicky I can see the CGI in the
eye I can tell it's CG I'm stupid in the
trailer Deadpool has a cable figure and
a Deadpool figure and they have
interaction there's a fun thing about
this is I don't know if that scene in
the trailer is actually a scene from the
movie that Deadpool is recreating with
figures I would love it if it is that's
kind of metaphor a Deadpool trailer I
feel Deadpool should do I'll be looking
out for that also I feel like there is
fourth wall breaking opportunity and the
fact that Josh Brolin is playing cable
in a Deadpool movie and he also plays
that out that just lends it for Deadpool
when he meets and being like you look
familiar I have seen you somewhere
you know pink face recalls loot crate
oven mitt it's coming but since that
kind of reference was thought up by
someone who literally talks in his
camera in a room at his house and not
you know the Hollywood big boys probably
not and after that we see what we would
expect from Deadpool shooting characters
jokes this view even one shot of TJ
Miller further ends with cable going
times up you dumb [ __ ] and I was
thinking that's just lazy anytime
someone says the word [ __ ] uses it as
a noun I've always found it lazy yeah
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] then Deadpool says
that's just lazy writing there you go I
love the fact that just the concept of
Deadpool lends it to a situation where
if they're filming something it didn't
maybe they didn't catch it before and
the line just seems lazy the leg where
you just have Deadpool reference it I
don't want it to overshadow
most of the movie like too many meta
jokes can bring a movie like this down
like I get it yeah fourth wall broke and
[ __ ] stay in the pocket concentrate on
the movie make the references where they
sprinkle in like icing on the cake you
can't make an entire cake out of icing
though they'd be kind of awesome to try
at least once
gotta be real my thoughts on Deadpool 2
are I expect to enjoy Deadpool 2 but not
as much as Deadpool 1 there's something
about the purity of Deadpool 1 Ryan
Reynolds wanted it made the studio
really didn't then that test footage was
leaked to the public and a bunch of fans
were like dude you gotta make it and so
it was made there's something beautiful
about that and there's something great
about the premise someone I love is in
danger I'm going to save them so we'll
see if Deadpool 2 keeps the magic of
Deadpool 1 or if it's basically a sequel
itis the rule of sequels as far as I'm
concerned is generally speaking with
exceptions in there don't expect the
second one to be as good as the first I
imagine it's gonna be a lot of fun right
so the trailer for Deadpool 2 where you
finally see Cable in action have you
seen it what you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you liked what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]